[Musica]
sono emozionatissimo essere qua con
questo panorama davanti ai miei occhi mi
fa veramente commuovere Oggi sono qui a
parlarvi di un piccolo oggetto un
piccolo manufatto va dal grandissimo
valore
affettivo la grandissima valore
emozionale anche dal punto di vista
sociale da grande valore da un punto di
vista tecnico e anche ambientale come
diceva prima Silvia il 30 di dicembre
del 2019 proprio qua è successo a questo
fatto drammatico che ha colpito tutta la
comunità valdostana
Edoardo era uno dei migliori amici di
mia figlia è cresciuto insieme lo
portavo a fare le gare lo portavo allo
stadio e quando è successo Questo fatto
non ci potevamo credere
ancora oggi soffriamo ovviamente ma
nell'inverno del 2020 un caro amico di
entrambi Bruno barayeur è venuto a casa
mia e mi ha detto massimo possiamo
pensare a qualcosa che
possa aiutare a ricordare a tutti noi
Edoardo possiamo pensare a un piccolo
oggetto un Bivacco
nella mia esperienza da architetto che
parte da lontano parte anche dallo
studio Albini e ho lavorato insieme a
Franca helde come assistente
universitario Mi sono laureato con lei
ho fatto il dottorato con lei quindi
vengo da quel mondo che ho sentito prima
enunciare dalla nipote e non avevo mai
fatto un Bivacco
vivo in montagna spesso amo la montagna
sono Uno sciatore un esperto sciatore Ma
questo confronto con un Bivacco non mi
aveva mai neanche
lontanamente colpito la mente
Allora ha iniziato come faccio di solito
a pensare usando ancora la matita Non
sono molto digitale e ho schizzato 12
diversi oggetti ma tutti avevano una
caratteristica
dovevano ricordare Edoardo ma anche Luca
che era scomparso insieme a lui quindi
doveva essere un oggetto ma da una forma
particolare una forma doppia
dai 12 schizzi ho chiamato i miei figli
mia figlia in quel periodo era in Olanda
a lavorare
e
ho condiviso questi schizzi con loro e
alla fine ne abbiamo scelto uno
abbiamo iniziato a svilupparlo insieme a
Bruno si era pensato di fare questo
oggetto in legno rivestirlo in lamiera
per poi posizionarlo nel punto uno dei
punti più cari a Edoardo Ieri c'è stato
alla Thuile il Trail di La Thuile che fu
inventato proprio da Edoardo un percorso
che parte dalla Thuile arriva su
ghiacciaio del ruitor torna alla Thuile
facendo vari giri
in questo punto abbiamo pensato di poter
collocare questo oggetto Come diceva
prima Silvia è lì davanti a noi Il
Bivacco è il ghiacciaio del ruitor
l'altezza è di 3.600 metri esisteva già
un Bivacco costruito nel 1800 ad altezza
di
3667 metri e allora abbiamo detto se è
stato lì per due secoli vuol dire che il
posto può essere
una buona scelta
e abbiamo iniziato a sviluppare il
progetto ma a un certo punto ho dovuto
anche chiedermi Ma quali sono le
condizioni
del meteo in quella zona a cosa deve
resistere questo oggetto lo vediamo qui
adesso questo vento molto forte a quella
quota è ancora più forte ma non lo
sapevamo non esisteva condizioni meteo
che ce li davano
ho chiamato dei miei amici dei colleghi
al Politecnico col dipartimento Wind del
vento sono riusciti a ottenere delle
informazioni dall'aeronautica militare
francese e ci han detto che sulla cima
del ruitor in quel punto il vento poteva
soffiare a 280 300 km all'ora
la temperatura poteva scendere a meno 30
meno 40 e quindi se avessimo messo
posizionato a quella quota un Bivacco in
legno molto probabilmente l'avremmo
trovato Aosta o forse anche a Torino e
allora abbiamo dovuto ripensare
completamente questo oggetto l'abbiamo
ripensato Grazie anche ad altri amici
che vengono alla Thuile altri
professionisti esperti ognuno nella sua
specialità un ingegnere Alberto Ferrari
esperto in strutture metalliche
strutturista un altro Alberto
aspetto sugli aspetti diciamo della
impiantistica e abbiamo studiato questo
oggetto in acciaio una struttura in
acciaio che doveva essere poi
rivestita con dei pannelli sandwich ad
alta capacità
coibente che potesse poi portare anche
un serramento per guardare al di fuori e
i bivacchi di solito sono di dimensioni
contenute devono poter offrire riparo
alle persone che sono in montagna che
possono trovare all'interno di questo
spazio di contenuti e dimensione però
rifugio e poter anche riprendersi e
allora abbiamo pensato che dovesse anche
poter portare Visto che tutti Oggi
viaggiamo con i telefonini la
possibilità di ricaricare il telefonino
la possibilità anche di trovare un
minimo di conforto e quindi il
riscaldamento la possibilità di avere
anche una illuminazione
va bene questo oggetto a sei posti ed è
stato realizzato in due oggetti sono due
oggetti piccoli due metri per 2 metri e
mezzo che sono stati composti visto che
questo è il tema sono stati realizzati
Grazie all'aiuto di diverse aziende sono
una ventina di aziende che ci hanno
aiutato alla realizzazione di questo
oggetto di questo manufatto è stato
realizzato e allestito in provincia di
Bergamo
trasportato alla Thuile nell'inverno
scorso del 2022 anche qui sembra tutto
semplice poter trasportare un manufatto
fatto di due oggetti agganciati tra di
loro alla Thuile da Bergamo ma
la vetrata
che
caratterizza l'edificio questo spazio
questo manufatto è una vetrata a taglio
termico con un vetro che ha dentro
dell'aria che è stato però allestito a
quota zero e doveva arrivare a 1.500
metri quindi abbiamo dovuto pensare a
come compensare questo vetro Durante la
salita e abbiamo posto per esempio dei
piccoli elementi che permettevano di
sfiatare Lasciatemi questo termine non
tecnico il vetro per evitare che si
frantumasse siamo arrivati l'abbiamo
installato nel piazzale di La Thuile
l'inverno scorso è rimasto lì In modo
tale che tutti potessero vederlo perché
il ghiacciaio del rutor non è così
facile da raggiungere oggi per andare
sulla cima del ruito Ci vogliono 8 ore
dalla Thuile e ci vuole anche una guida
per arrivare sul ghiacciaio quindi ci
vogliono più esperte Allora abbiamo
lasciato
nel piazzale della funivia in modo tale
che tutti potessero vederlo potessero
guardare questo oggetto che ricordava
Edoardo all'interno di questa struttura
in lamiera vi è un rivestimento in legno
che ricopre tutto l'elemento coibente e
su questo
diciamo rivestimento in legno c'è anche
il volto di Edoardo stampato a fuoco e
impresso a fuoco in modo tale da
ricordarcelo ancora di più
L'inverno è passato e l'estate scorsa
abbiamo portato questo oggetto in quota
dove doveva arrivare per portarlo in
quota però sono nati altri problemi
l'avevamo studiato con pesi specifici ci
avevano detto che l'elicottero un
elicottero speciale a doppia Pala che
arrivava dalla Svizzera poteva portare
fino a 2500 kg Quindi abbiamo
progettato questo oggetto che pesava
2.400 kg a blocco sono che l'estate
scorsa caldissima
ha cambiato i piani con il calore con
l'innalzamento delle temperature gli
elicotteri perdono portanza e quindi
abbiamo dovuto
scomporre tutto il manufatto non solo
nei due pezzi abbiamo dovuto smontare
tutto quello che c'era dentro e
l'abbiamo dovuto portare a 1.900 kg
l'uno perché l'elicottero porta 9000 kg
all'altezza del mare ma a 3000 metri
Anzi a 3.600 metri Rimanendo in stallo
per poter posizionarla a montarlo
riusciva a malapena arrivare ai 2000 kg
Quindi abbiamo rivisto completamente
questo progetto l'abbiamo disassemblato
e finalmente ad agosto del 2022
l'abbiamo portato in quota
sono serviti più di 70 voli con
elicotteri di più piccole dimensioni e
l'elicottero che sta girando qua che
vedete è uno degli elicotteri che ci ha
aiutato a poter rimontare e ricomporre
Il Bivacco in quota oggi è lì al suo
posto settimana due settimane fa siamo
riusciti anche a fare l'inaugurazione
che l'anno scorso non era riuscita
l'inaugurazione ufficiale con le
istituzioni con i sindaci perché il
meteo non ci permette di arrivare in
quota sempre e così facilmente e dalla
sopra noi vediamo questo è questo
manufatto che ha una forma come dicevo
prima doppia per ricordare Edo e Luca ma
anche perché è a cavallo di due valli la
valle di La Thuile e la valle di
Valgrisenche Scusate ma il vento qui è
veramente fortissimo
è a cavallo di due paesi dell'Italia
della Francia e l'abbiamo posizionato in
modo tale che la vetrata guardi il Monte
Bianco immaginando che Edoardo sia lì a
guardarci in questo momento dalle cime
del ghiacciaio del rutto e questo spazio
dicevo prima oltre alla Valenza forte
emotiva anche una valenza tecnica e
tecnologica È un Bivacco che
autoalimentato abbiamo coperto la parte
superiore
della struttura con dei pannelli
fotovoltaici che sono in grado di
produrre energia elettrica che viene
accumulata con delle batterie batterie
speciali che abbiamo trovato che possano
resistere a quella quota batterie
ecologiche Questa batteria porta energia
All'interno c'è una pavimentazione che è
riscaldata In modo tale che se si arriva
anche in condizioni il meteo difficili
si possa trovare un tepore poi il tepore
delle 6 persone che stanno in 10 metri
quadri aiuta Sicuramente ma in quei
momenti di difficoltà ci si può anche
collegare perché c'è un'antenna che
permette il collegamento
via wi-fi con la valle ma anche visto le
difficoltà che avevamo trovato per
ottenere l'informazione abbiamo
posizionato una stazione meteo la
stazione metro più alta e della Alpi
Graie a 3.500 metri quindi oggi se voi
andate sul sito il sito di bivacco
Edoardo Camardella trovate anche due
connessioni Una è quella per vedere le
condizioni meteo quest'inverno il vento
non è stato troppo forte è arrivato fino
a 180 Km all'ora quindi ha resistito
bene e poi trovate anche un'altra cosa
una telecamera
è una telecamera che ci ha offerto
skyway è una telecamera a 360 gradi noi
siamo stati diciamo anche artefici di
trovare questa telecamera l'abbiamo
offerta anche a skyway e la stanno
usando anche loro e se andate sono
connesse le quattro telecamere della
zona e quindi potete avere una visione
complessiva di questo grandissimo
spettacolare
Colpo d'occhio che è la Valle d'Aosta e
questo luogo quindi tornando
all'oggetto è stato uno sforzo uno
sforzo di un gruppo un gruppo
inizialmente di amici a cui si sono
affiancate delle aziende che ci hanno
aiutato che ci hanno permesso di
arrivare alla realizzazione di questo
piccolo come dicevo prima oggetto ma dal
grandissimo valore e tutte le volte che
qualcuno arriva al Bivacco Noi siamo
sicuri che Edoardo da lassù sarà molto
più contento Grazie a tutti